- All right,
- we can't end the hour without
one last feel good story.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
Many of the greatest guitarists
in rock and roll history
have humble roots.
Eddie Van Halen hand-made
his first guitar.
As a kid,
Keith Richard stacked books
to reach his grandfather's
guitar on a high shelf.
And Jimi Hendrix's first guitar
only had one string,
but throughout history,
we've never witnessed the
birth of a rock and roll legend
in real time.
That is until this year.
People, witness history.
- Oh, he's playing a little rock music.
(kid exclaiming) (guitar strings plucking)
- Wow.
Wow.
(audience laughing)
All right, coming to the end.
All right, everybody give him a hand!
- Little man was rocking
so hard. He was shaking.
I've got to get Jocko's reaction, Jocko.
Do you think he has what it takes?
- That guy is awesome. (laughing)
- That's full heat!
And I love that he just kept
going, like, you're like,
okay, I get it.
Nope.
I'm gonna keep going!
- The teacher kept going, oh, oh.
Oh.
He turned the guitar up
and started (laughing)
- He's got all the moves!
- Oh my God, he's so great.
The little boy's name is Crew.
Better known as Rock On Crew.
And we have him on the line
along with his mama Hannah.
So Hannah.
Oh my gosh. You are so gorgeous.
So the teacher's reaction was hilarious.
Was she slightly scared?
- That is a great question.
So I prepared her a little bit
because Crew has always loved rock music.
And I told her right before,
because I wasn't allowed to be there.
I said, you know,
he's got a special song
prepared for you guys.
And she told me right
after, she's like, you know,
I wasn't really prepared for that,
but I thought he maybe
like got his fingers caught
in the strings and leaned over to check.
Yeah. Just like that.
And she says,
but then after I realized he
was just feeling the music.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my gosh. It's amazing.
So there was a song you
were supposed to sing.
So how did it go?
(unintelligible kid talk)
- Thank you teachers,
we love you teachers.
- You are so amazing, little man!
Oh my God.
So where do you think Crew
gets his inspiration here?
Are y'all just like rocking out at home?
- Yeah. Yeah, tell her.
- The rockers!
- He tells me that rockers
give him inspiration,
but really who taught him, is?
- Daddy!
- Daddy taught him.
(audience clapping)
- Awww!
- Yeah. I grew up-
- Let me do it!
My mom grow up playing the piano.
My dad grow up playing drums.
And he loved rocker music better.
- Yeah, I grew up playing the piano.
My husband grew up playing the drums
and so Crew naturally
loves rock music better.
- Oh my gosh. Well Crew,
at some point you're going
to have to come on our show
and you're going to have
to play with my band.
This would be amazing is all I'm saying.
If you came and rocked out with
us, would you be into that?
- Say yeah!
- Yeah!
- All right, thank you so much, Hannah.
And thanks Rock On Crew
I'm liking your post right now.
He's getting his fingers ready. I love it.
That's not all though!
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show
wants to honor ultimate
overachievers, just like Crew.
So they're going to be writing you
a check for a thousand dollars.
(audience cheering)
Crew, this is your first paying gig.
Yeah!